the premise of the movie is set far in
the future humankind as a race is
evolving at its own pace when one
discovery changes everything a massive
fireball similar to the sun is
approaching the earth at high speed time
passes and soon enough the earth faces
the effects of having two suns heat
radiation and unnatural gravitational
pull kill billions and put human life at
risk the second sun will take about 200
years to gradually fly away from the
solar system and by then humankind will
be long extinct to avoid the worst case
scenario a group of survivors build a
self-sustaining underground city called
ember its resources and food supply are
predicted to last for 200 years after
which humans will be allowed to return
to the surface however they can only do
so using a very specific path that can
be accessed only by using a map the path
is kept a secret to avoid curious people
exploring it before the time comes
meanwhile the map and the instructions
are kept in a locker timed at 200 years
the very first mayor of ember gets to
keep the box and as time goes by it is
handed down from mayor to mayor
everything goes according to plan until
one day the current mayor dies and the
safe is forgotten about just like that
200 years pass and the box opens on its
own but no one pays attention to its
contents and it remains unused inside a
closet the ember city is powered by a
singular generator that is on the verge
of breaking down moreover the canned
food supply which is kept in the
treasury is also running out at a
frightening rate then we are introduced
to the city's social and work
environment after graduating high school
every youngster is assigned to a job
based on a random draw some get to be
the mailman others get to work the food
while the luckiest ones get to become
youtube narrators
just kidding they're kept in charge of
the generator likewise the next
graduating class has an ambitious young
man named doon he has always been
interested in machines following in his
father's footsteps who is a famous
mechanic dune eagerly wants to be
designated to repair the generator but
his dreams are crushed when he is made
the mailman of the city what a nerd he
is best friends with a girl named lena
who is assigned to be the city pipe
handler okay
since it was her childhood dream to
become a mailman dune secretly allows
her to change professions with him this
way he gets to be close to the generator
because the city pipelines are laid
around the same area at night lena
excitedly tells her grandmother about
her profession the old woman knows
something about the secret passageway
but she has dementia and has forgotten
most of it lena's late father also had
an idea about the exit path which is
proven true through his final voice
message that they listen to in his
memory he has described the outside
world very vaguely in the voice message
hence the girls think of it as gibberish
someone named barrow is also mentioned
at one point but no one of such name
resides in the city therefore the girls
never thought anything of it the
following day is lena's first day at
work she happily distributes letters
until a loud commotion is heard a
homeless man is being apprehended for
spreading false rumors because he claims
to have seen giant insects in the dark
side of the city where no one is allowed
to go no one believes him but lena finds
a body part that the man dropped which
looks too much like a giant beetle horn
elsewhere dune also reports on the first
day of his job and instantly notices the
rusty pipes and broken spare parts his
boss is a grumpy old man named saul who
has been in this line of work his entire
life he knows everything about the
city's pipelines and is well aware that
it is at risk of being flooded sull
wants dune to refrain from using his
brain because the city workers have
tried everything and given up on finding
a permanent fix to the problems dune is
handed the helmet of a dead worker
before he is put to work he keeps the
mentor's words in mind but is adamant
about looking for a solution refusing to
let his people die in a flood later that
day he steals the pipeline map from saul
and starts exploring the tunnels he
eventually comes across a room named 351
it peaks his interest because the room
is not on the map and is locked dune
decides to ignore it for now and
continues the exploration to reach
another dark and mysterious tunnel no
one knows what it leads to and it is too
scary to explore walking further dune
ends up inside the city's food storage
unit which is almost empty while looking
around he is caught by the food guard
looper no one in the city likes him
because he was previously accused of
stealing cans of food but wasn't
convicted if i were looper i'd be
sneaking bites too then suddenly the
generator stops working leaving the city
in complete darkness the engineers do
their best to fix it temporarily but
everyone knows it won't work for a long
time after work that night lena goes
home to her frantic grandmother telling
her about a box in the closet it turns
out that her great-grandfather was the
mayor who died without passing the safe
down she finally checks the closet to
find the years old safe but doesn't know
what to do with it the next day at work
lena meets looper the infamous guard of
the food storage unit he gives her a
letter to hand over to the current mayor
at the mayor's mansion lena sees a
drawer full of cans and notices the
mayor trying to hide it her eyes also
land on a picture of her
great-grandfather where he is holding
the box she found in the closet
meanwhile people are starting to suffer
from the first stage of food and
medicine shortage they are preparing
themselves for the inevitable big
blackout lena shows dune the beetle horn
she found yesterday and dune confirms
with the textbooks to ensure it is
authentic dune's father is an expert in
such things but has no answer to how a
beetle can be so big moreover he wants
his son to stop being curious about the
things outside the city after the failed
meeting with his father lina shows dune
the contents of the safe it has a shiny
glass plate a torn piece of paper and a
bunch of strange markings they put
together the torn page and to discover
it has the instructions for the way out
of the city it tells them to use the
locked door 351 to find the said passage
the duo sneaks into the tunnels to
investigate further but is caught by a
limping man he runs away as soon as he
sees them and drops many food cans on
the way dune is shocked because the cans
are of a food that the city ran out of a
long time ago before they investigate
further a gigantic star-nosed mole
attacks them and they have to escape
through the tunnels when things calm
down a little lena notices her father's
name written on dune's helmet meaning he
was the worker who died wearing it dune
reveals that he drowned while working in
the pipelines later lena returns home
and asks her aunt lane about her
father's death lane discloses that her
father was obsessed with finding a way
out of the city and had discovered the
shortest path however he drowned while
on the final part of the mission lina is
shocked by how tragic her father's death
was she is distracted by her thoughts
when she notices looper limping down the
street it reminds her of the person in
the tunnels and she quickly goes to tell
dune the two then finally open the door
to room 351 and find it filled with food
supplies that the mayor has collected
for himself it is more than enough to
last him a lifetime while his people die
of starvation sounds familiar the duo
does not wake up the sleeping mayor and
returns to lisa's house they listen to
her father's recording again and this
time dune recognizes the person barrow
mentioned in the message as his father
he runs to the old man and inquires
about the tunnels and lena's father it
is revealed that barrow and lena's
father were partners on a mission to
find an exit they were never successful
and barrow's close friends lost their
lives because of their obsessions with
looking for an exit therefore he didn't
want to tell dune about the mission not
wanting his son to go down the same path
best if his son just dies instead dune
understands his father's concerns but is
adamant about completing the task that
they started moreover he has the help of
the map and the box unlike they did in
the past elsewhere lena tries to expose
the mayor but is caught the lights go
off at the right time giving her a
chance to steal the mayor's batch and
run away she and dune are on the list of
wanted criminals and have nowhere to go
in such a situation they use a special
vehicle to run to the generator room
then they join the stolen mayor batch
and the glass they found in the box to
create a key with the symbol of the
generator on it they think it is the key
to the room but are wrong lena inspects
the instructions and discovers that they
have to look behind the locker for
something upon checking they reveal a
secret chamber behind one of the lockers
that consists of several more empty
lockers the use for these is unknown but
the next instruction asks them to move a
wheel clockwise as soon as they do so
the lockers line up and slide into the
generator room even a baby could have
solved that riddle the door to the room
finally opens and they come face to face
with a subterranean river connected to a
massive piece of machinery the locker is
not actually used to hold things but was
made as a boat to transfer humans to the
surface however to make it work they
still have to raise the water level
above a massive wheel stopping the
river's path they go through the next
instruction which asks them to enter the
emergency control room the badge finally
comes to use as the key and they go into
the chamber that has levers and buttons
to control the entire machine they
activate the wheel as the instruction
asks them which causes the water level
to rise slowly however the plan
backfires when the sudden surge of
pressure causes the lights in the city
to glow brighter and eventually break
the people are even more scared when the
pipelines break putting the city at risk
of being flooded the mayor thinks this
is the end and goes to his waterproof
chamber to save his life but karma
catches up to him when he is attacked by
a giant mole and killed before everyone
else suddenly the wheel stops working
and the pipeline worker saul comes to
save the day he fixes the wheel but has
to keep on holding a lever for it to
continue working it is an extremely
dangerous task but he recognizes that it
is the only way people's lives can be
saved the water level rises immediately
after the wheel is fixed and dune has to
reluctantly leave saul to look for an
exit after that dune lena and her little
sister sit on the locker boat and a
massive wave pushes them above and away
from the wheel the three go down a
series of dark and scary tunnels hoping
to be alive when everything is over they
almost give up when they slide down a
steep slope but when they open their
eyes again they find themselves in a
pond a few meters away is a bright door
which finally leads them to the surface
of the earth the duo is not as happy as
they should be because it is night time
and they assume the outside is just as
dark as the inside but then they witness
their first sunrise and their eyes go
blind i mean sparkle with joy the land
is inhabitable again and they can
finally live a fulfilled life suddenly
the group notices a bird and follows it
to reach a very deep hole they can see a
hint of ember city from this height but
their voice doesn't reach down below as
a last resort they tie the map and their
messages to a rock and throw it inside
fortunately dune's father receives the
message and the entirety of the city is
saved how will they get out though
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching